the Ted Cruz filibuster in the Senate
just ended I think it went around 21
hours but since it just ended I don't
have the exact number on me at this
moment now interestingly he was
filibustering a Republican passed bill
in the house that was going to defund
Obamacare so he's a Republican
filibustering a republican-led bill
nothing will come of this
Obamacare obviously is going through
this is the president's signature thing
in his entire his legacy will basically
be based in this so nothing is going to
happen with it but let's let's watch a
little bit of Ted this is 21 hours of
talking this was about I think 10 hours
in he also I will tell I will credit my
father he invented this wasn't for the
restaurant but he did it anyway he
invented green eggs and ham he did it
two ways one the easy way is he put
green green food coloring and eggs
chopped up ham in it and as a kid green
eggs and ham was my favorite book when I
was a little boy and so he would make me
green eggs and ham you can actually do
it the food coloring is a little bit
cheating but if you actually take
something like spinach and mix it into
the eggs the eggs turn green okay before
I directly address that I did do a
little research on this obviously green
eggs and ham was written by dr. Seuss
and according to my research he's not
even a doctor so I don't know who he's
quoting and he's really doing this
Meadowvale care that was a terrible joke
okay so there were 21 hours of this that
was the in a way that ended up being
like the least of the crazy things that
were going on he started making all
these Star Wars comparisons I liked
actually what what is the purpose of
this you know at least when Rand Paul
did the anti drone thing everyone seemed
to back him and there was this idea that
you two can have a drone showing up and
blowing you up when you walk out
7-eleven or something but this became
more of a mockery is this just purely
like him going for 2016 like I need to
boost my profile I'm gonna talk for 21
straight hours for the bragging rights
hashtag filibuster master I mean look if
he was reading you know Fifty Shades of
Grey I might have tuned in but yes he
did it I feel like just watching the
little clips that I did it was like I'm
listening to his therapy session out
loud so maybe that's why he did I mean
you
hear yourself talk for that long it's
like you're just he's like discovering
that although we thought was kind of
cheating with the yeah with the green
thing maybe with the spin it's like okay
you know whatever but yeah I absolutely
think he did it for to say that he did
it yeah because there really was no
reason yeah so before we get too glib
about it if he really believes that
somehow giving universal health care is
going to destroy the country because so
many countries in the in the past had
been destroyed by health care right like
that's like everyone knows that
obviously if he really believes it then
he did do the right thing and we should
try to give him a pass what do you what
do you think I think you did it for the
bragging rights I think that there's
some like it's like some southern
barbecue house where they have like can
you eat this 25 pound burger right like
there's like Wendy Davis and haven't you
know like there's like all pictures of
politicians who have successfully done
it and how many hours the frustrating
point like part here is that on Capitol
Hill you don't have it's incredibly
liberal on what you can but the
technical terms are of what you can talk
about you yeah Wendy Davis got out stood
at the eleventh hour for slightly
getting off-topic he's here talking
about Nightmare on Elm Street answering
questions about you know horse hair
combs whatever the hell and and it's
it's to me it's it's creating a mockery
out of the overall thing that he's
standing for you know yeah it doesn't
have it it's not impressive point to me
that he can stand for 21 hours and talk
yeah also I'm not sure if people quite
understand this point which I've been
tweeting a lot about that you know the
Senate and Congress they have special
health care that no one else has access
to already so this is a man who has
specialized health care filibustering
and trying to stop the rest of regular
people of getting universal health care
so the irony somehow the irony I mean
also the fact that he's standing there
and he's talking about how he's
representing the general public and
that's his goal to be the people's voice
his issues that he stands on completely
go against the popular opinion on gun
control and a couple different things
well there is that Texas thing so it's
like he's very
the country you know I don't know I just
think that he's just completely
bass-ackwards and everything yeah it's
not what politics is about though I feel
like this is kind of a mirror to the
Obama speech it's like he genuinely is
against it and he thinks that it's gonna
fail and that it's gonna be you know the
demise of the country so he wants to be
able to say for the record people do you
remember that I went on a fillip but you
know I mean right so it's just like
Obama being like hey man I put my hand
out to shake it you didn't show up this
day okay so I've been thinking about
this a lot does that make you guys think
that you know I talk about this stuff
every week oh and that's what all these
news networks are doing but that really
it's just this big charade this big you
know house of cards if you watch the
show you know it's all this backwards
back deal stuff where everyone's just
covering their ass constantly in a
country where he can legitimately read
green eggs and ham the whole book you
know and everybody is okay with it
apparently it's just like I mean other
countries with the universal health care
are just looking at us laughing like
what is this yeah and rightfully so
apparently yeah what they I'm sort of
fascinated with this is that the media
coverage of this was a little bizarre
because Fox obviously likes Ted Cruz
they were showing a lot of it CNN at one
point had him in the little box with no
sound you know while they show something
else and MSNBC was actually showing
video of why it's ridiculous what he's
doing which I guess is all a standard
stuff